so before we get started can people have
a show of hands how many people are
consider themselves savvy Python people
like ready to use Python happy about it
I mean people consider themselves kind
of Python newbies used to some other
language but trying it out okay
how many people are well versed in the
SyFy and Python for data science stack
like you use all the tools use pandas
you stop okay how many people have used
map plot live either pandas plot or
however okay all right that's a good
start
if anyone is sitting next to somebody
who raised themselves raise their hand
has a relative newbie you could just
raise your hands again if you're pretty
new to Python if you're sitting next to
a person like that help them out please
with me they are running into problems
you're the expert
I'm Jim Bednar I'll be presenting this
at least unless my voice gives out this
is my colleague jean-luc Stevens we're
both from anaconda which is local we've
seen lots anaconda people around here
and former anaconda people who are now
starting their own companies and such
it's kind of cool all right so the
post-it notes are for your laptop please
put a green one on there if you have
anything running if you've followed the
instructions and you have something
running either locally or by clicking on
the cloud thing everyone should have a
unique user name and password for the
cloud offering and so you shouldn't be
stepping on each other's toes unless I
made a typo but you are all still
sharing the same machines so there's a
big there are a couple of 40 node
clusters that these accounts are on so
if some if everybody's running something
enormous at the same time it is possible
you'll step on each other's toes
probably not we're not being very
ambitious in this talk but just be aware
it's a shared resource and of course
Wi-Fi is a shared resource so everybody
is kinda installing an environment at
the same time you might be fighting each
other for bandwidth
okay so put your red post-it note up if
you're having problems following the
instructions if you're just working hard
and haven't finished it then no post-it
note green if you're done if it works
because I want to see a lot of greens
before I get heavily into anything okay
okay if I fail to spot a red one right
wave it at me and I'll send don't look
over to help you out okay all right so
to make you so good use of the time I'll
start but I won't be assuming everyone's
ready to follow along so I'll just be
showing off some stuff at the start so
don't worry if you're not done setting
up keep setting up that's your main goal
to get something running in fact that's
what I want you to walk out of here
today with there are emissions are low
we want you to have run something they
have successfully running that is the
only goal here really well to be exposed
to some other stuff but to have run
something yourself so if you're not able
to set it up and it's not working that's
something to work on and we can help you
with that all right so this is the basic
structure of the talk can people see
this in the back of the room it's bright
enough okay thank you so we're in the
setup phase right now then I'll have a
background and demos kind of show you
various examples of things that you will
not be able to do during this session
they're more ambitious than that and
then we'll start out for what's kind of
a one-liner
make a dashboard with one line of code
and you can play around with that for a
while then we'll say okay step back and
do it a little more step-by-step and
then be more ambitious so it's okay if
you get to here and aren't able to do
the further exercises at least you'll
have done something if you're failing it
exercise one pull somebody in talk to
your neighbor you hopefully you get
something working at least alright if
you've got something running you can run
this first let me restart and clear
everything I suppose I should have asked
how many people have used a Jupiter
notebook
how many people have not used a Jupiter
notebook great I will fail to explain
lots of things then okay so the first
cell in this notebook is just to make
sure things are installed properly all
it is doing is checking the versions of
panel pandas matplotlib okay and Holle
abuse if you if it succeeds you'll see
nothing if you see error messages
something went horribly wrong and it's
worth figuring it out alright so at the
beginning I'll just give you an idea of
what the heck panel is first off go to
the website panel is an app and
dashboard development system for Python
now apps and dashboards what I mean by
that is basically a website but it's a
website that you write in Python it's a
website that you can easily have data
and plots and all of your PI data
basically everything that's that's in
Python and as data related should be
easily able to be turned into a website
it's to be turned into something you can
share with people and turn into
something interactive in Python
now obviously you could go and write a
website in HTML and in JavaScript and
CSS if that's your thing go for it bye
this is for python for people who are
comfortable in Python and want to stay
in Python but still want their work to
have an impact want to be able to share
it to other people who aren't
necessarily gung-ho about Python but you
still want to make an impact on those
people or just for your own purposes you
just want to be able to set up something
interactive to play with yourself maybe
I shouldn't said that that way anyway
alright so back to the task at hand
panel is a open source library developed
by anaconda and we developed it as part
of our services group the services group
has contracts with government agencies
and with companies all over the world
and basically we listen to their
problems and then we tell them an
open-source way to solve their problems
and suddenly their problems over and
over we're about how to build a
dashboard and how to empower their day
scientists to make an impact on the
decision-makers in the company and
previously what people but people told
us over and over is I've got my Jupiter
notebook it looks great and then I hand
it over to the JavaScript team and six
months later they make an app and it
isn't right and we work and then
eventually it's sort of okay and
meanwhile the business has moved on
that is not how things are supposed to
work you're supposed to be able to be a
data scientist you discover amazing
things you find cool transit you want to
explore them and then you want to share
it with people are going to make a
decision fund that can that project do
this whatever you need to make decisions
so we over and over kept hearing from
people who had trouble linking up their
cool data scientists to actually justify
their salaries for having an impact on
the organization so we listed we kept
hearing this over and over and then we
said okay we're gonna break down we're
gonna build this as an app and we're
gonna build some library that makes it
easy to connect up something you got
working in Jupiter to being something
you can deploy now at the same time
we're building this other people started
building other things
voilá has anyone heard of that that is a
sort of competing tool for some of the
things and all kind of point out where
it word overlaps and where it competes
voila let's you take a different
notebook and deploy it as well it
doesn't have any special features to
make that easy but it will it can take a
jupiter notebook and lets you deploy
that panel can be used whipped together
with voila but we're gonna focus on
talking about panel here because we
can't really control that now there's
also a package called dash dash is a
little different - doesn't take do for
notebooks - just for building dashboards
in Python but only if you're building a
dashboard where panel does is try to say
you're working with the jupiter notebook
you make something you add a few widgets
you make it a little bit interactive and
you gradually build up an app and
eventually you build up a dashboard
eventually you build up a multi-page
dash for it eventually becomes somehow a
complicated system but you never had to
switch tools along the way so - is not
like that - is okay I did some stuff now
I'm gonna build a dashboard in -
throwing away all of that voilá is more
similar to panel in that way you have
notebook
and you can deploy it so voila and panel
are more similar all right so here's
just some random examples these are all
taken from the links here examples up by
biz or the panel gallery this is the
panel gallery and I've already opened
some hopefully they're still running
here just to clarify there are two types
of deployed panel apps one is where
there's Python running so you click on
things you're in a web browser something
gets eventually transferred to a Python
server some computation happens and you
see the result
that's a Python backed app and if you go
to the panel website some of the things
you'll see there are Python back other
ones were written in Python but the
final result is has no Python in it it's
just some deployed HTML Javascript and
whatever I think one of these is okay
here this one is an example of a
deployed app here that it whoa that is
only JavaScript so this thing is written
in Python and usually this is panel code
you'll get to that the final result is a
is an app with widgets and so on is all
connected up but the result is in
JavaScript hopefully that doesn't hurt
you in any way basically you write a
specification most of these are
declarative it's declaring what you want
the exilim indentation of it is in
JavaScript so most of the things you'll
see are different they require like this
one requires a running Python process
and so if you've not visited the page in
a while as I haven't I have to reload
and I'll start what's called a session
I'm here in my browser if I drag
something here it will send a command
over to the Python process some
computation will happen things will come
back and it gets updated in the browser
that's a Python back system so this
Python back system in this case is
drawing some pretty pictures basically
this particular one okay yeah this one
is deployed on the cloud there's some
ATO AWS server that's burning some money
as I do this
my employer pays so whereas this the
other one I showed you here that's all
happening inside the browser so there's
some JavaScript code eventually it just
gets sandal it in the browser at the
computations happening in the browser
there are pros and cons if you have a
Python server you know anything you can
basically any possible computation you
can write in Python you can have
something on that page that triggers
that and you get the result and if
you've made it into something that
happens only in the royal tour then you
can easily just email it to people so
they're frozen cons will show you both
see this is one that was well it was
running so this is just something to
help you explore a little mathematical
thing yeah it has one widget you get to
choose what your function field is that
one's a boring one and then you can look
around whenever you click something
happens in the browser it selects your
mouse click there's out where you are in
this plot sends it to Python Python
computes a function plots it goes to the
browser okay so this is this one's
Python backed this one couldn't be done
in the browser because this is 213
glaciers in the world you can select on
each of one of these things and all
these plots are interlinked this
particular plot is done by program
called data shader that turns data into
images and that all happens at the
Python side the server side the image
goes into the browser so the browser
doesn't crash even though there are
millions and millions well in this case
only 213 but this could barely probably
work in our web browsers but it can work
with millions this particular one is a
billion GPS locations here this couldn't
happen in the browser so it advised them
in here what's happening is it sent a
request to fight on toll Python to
render it and now it's going to re
render
you can actually see the delay with
Python here because this is a huge data
set it's just on my laptop do you see
what's happening there so this is the
sort of thing that you can only really
do with Python in JavaScript because the
browser's model of how to manage memory
does not involve a billion points it
will never as far as I know involves a
very small sort of thing sandbox for me
every other browser tab but if I find
can handle whatever size of data you
want okay one thing I have well this
this shows a little bit of one thing I
don't have a good example of we've
tentacle created a lot of these for our
clients and then we can share them a
complex multi-page apps they're hard to
share as examples this particular one is
not one that we've made for a client so
we could share that it but it's not also
it's also not very multi-page it has a
few tabs but you can actually use these
tools to create things that are whole
websites and have state that persists
across multiple pages and such that's
much more complicated but just so you
know there's Headroom you can build
quite complex things all still in Python
okay I think I'm done with demos and
ready to move on to actual work so I do
not see any red on anything so I see
some things without a green post-it if
you have something running of any sort
please put a green post-it on your
machine if you're having problems and
have nothing running please wave a red
post-it and make sure we know okay I
guess we're ready to get started before
we do does anyone have any questions so
far just see if you're in the right
place or have some basic a question yes
[Music]
yep yep yep well we'll get to that there
are a lot of a lot of options one of the
simplest ways is if you have something
that has let's just put up something
here that has a widget something that is
very general that could work in all
cases but you'll immediately see the
limitations is if no matter what is here
this is a function of these values now
what is the if you had one slider and it
had ten values you would just need to
export to the browser ten plots to
handle one slider but what if this one
has ten sliders and this this one has
ten and this also has ten in this and so
on that space of possible things to
export to the browser well very general
you can handle anything it'll
immediately become a very large thing
that you're trying to export to the
browser because you're essentially
pre-computing everything you might ever
ask for in python getting it down to the
final javascript HTML static stuff and
shipping all that to the browser that is
always going to work but it's in
technical terms but it may eventually
it'll quickly overwhelm your browser so
there are other things you can do which
involve figuring out a way to link this
using javascript to this you write the
two lines of JavaScript and it connects
up directly and there are other things
where we've already done that for you
for simple things like having something
to control the color map that just has
already been solved in JavaScript so we
can do it in Python but we also hand
through in a little thing where we did
that connecting up directly and but in
JavaScript so some so there's a
complicated answer basically in Python
you have can do anything you want some
subset of those will immediately map
directly to JavaScript being done even
if you can't have that you can do this
exhaustively collect all the data and do
that that's also automatic if you want
anything more ambitious you're gonna
have to do a little work so basically if
you can count on Python being there you
can avoid all the work you're gonna stay
in Python do some Python get some app
and if you can count on there being
Python to deliver it you're done beyond
that you do more work
yes sure I guess the underlying panel
works with a ton of underlying libraries
and as long as the underlying libraries
have ways to generate SVG typically than
you then turn into PDF PDF that can work
you can also just hit print on a
particular page in your browser and that
often works but it's not intended if you
take a step back the underlying Jupiter
notebook is usually easier to turn into
a PDF so behind this thing is a notebook
with maybe twelve lines of code that
notebook is much better set up to be
able to turn directly into PDF so
typically you'll have a workflow where
if you want to have a report you have a
notebook and you spit out a report
that's based on that turn that notebook
into a PDF and then you can also turn
that notebook into a live running
dashboard but we haven't typically
turned it into a dashboard and into a
PDF because basically this is waiting
for a user to do something whereas the
notebook can laid out all the choices
I'm having been made automatically
without a user and one final point is
that all the panel Doc's that you'll see
online those are all generate it from
notebooks turned into HTML and so once
those are in your browser you of course
you can save those to PDF there so
that's a notebook to browser to PDF
workflow but good question anything else
before we start
okay let's actually run something so I
cleared my notebook here if you've
already been playing around you might
want to clear your notebook again like I
said this is a not very ambitious
set of data here it's not a large data
set as not a complicated data set this
is meant to get used to give you some
success so this particular data set
we're reading it's appropriate here as
it gets a little hot is measuring the
characteristics of a meeting room
the temperature in Celsius I guess
humidity how many people that might have
to just be whether it's occupied and
over a series of time points so it's
basically somebody instrumented a
meeting rooms climate control put that
out as a standard data set so it's in a
pandas dataframe panel doesn't care what
type of data hey you have whether it's a
panda data frame it cares that it's
something that can be visualized
particularly if it can be visualized in
a Jupiter notebook so this particular
one you can see it's got some columns
and now let's say we've figured out a
way to plot it in this particular one we
wrapped it up as a function because
we're going to want to call this over
and over but we wrote two functions here
one is basically the idea is that we're
going to smooth want to pick one of
these columns smooth the values slightly
and then plot it so here we write a
function at the moment it's using
matplotlib
but we'll use other plotting libraries
and it's given two sets of data one is
the time series and one is a subset of
that time series that we'll use to
highlight it you'll you'll see in a
minute and also we're going to we have a
function that's that will try to compute
given a time series and a smooth time
series find outliers find things that
are very far from the smooth value what
we're doing here actually mit doesn't
matter at all
I'm just trying to explain it just think
of it as something that makes a plot
okay so here's here we're calling this
function we're looking at the
temperature oh we've plotted the
temperature so that's the the raw
temperature and then smooth it with a
running average window of size 20 data
points and we're gonna highlight all the
data points that are I guess 10 Sigma's
away from the
smooth mean and so what that does is
here this is it's basically highlighting
areas of shark change and if we want to
mess around with that we can change that
how far away do you have to be to be
highlighted if you have us if you have
some distribution you don't have to beat
in sigma's away you only have to be five
you'll get more data points highlighted
right and eventually you highlight
everything okay you can keep doing this
if you're a Jupiter programmer and
Python programmer you can have a
function like this you can explore this
parameter space you can do that already
you don't need panel but it's awkward
and painful I mean but - it's you have
to keep you don't know what the allowed
values of Sigma are you don't know what
the allowed values of window are you
just type it and you study the code and
so on so it takes some Python knowledge
to work with that even for this totally
trivial function plus if we wanted to
share this with our boss and we wanted
the boss to understand oh okay this is
the parameter then you need to watch for
this is what we're trying to optimize
for they're not gonna be happy with this
so we're trying to immediately get you
to be successful so we give you a
one-liner this is I mentioned voila
voila can use I play widgets I play what
just has a function called interact you
can do the same thing we're showing here
roughly the same syntax to use with I pi
widgets and voila so up to this point
you can use whatever library you feel
like this is not know this is panel
panel is PN so panel dot interact it's
just copying the I pi widgets API so now
if we do this now we have this function
and we you notice that we haven't
immediately got two widgets and if we
drag the widgets we can see what the
effect of Sigma is and we can see what
the effect of the rolling window is
without with essentially zero work
yeah so let's see how that works so that
this is the magic function so how does
the magic work the magic won't always
work so we got to understand the magic
okay so what's the magic this find
outliers function that's what we're
calling with interact and it has one two
three four four arguments why didn't we
get four widgets because the magic only
goes so far look at the widgets we got
we got one for window and one for Sigma
what other what other widgets do we need
oh well there's a variable which selects
a column in the data set
the Interac doesn't have any idea what
the columns in your data said it doesn't
know that there is a data set it has no
way to know if the value defaults to
temperature that it could be anything
else those could be any ASCII string
right or Unicode and what about this one
view fun well that takes this function
here how does it know what possible
functions you could get it doesn't so
what interact does is to make it be
useful it does what it can okay I'll
I'll deal with it I ignore the things I
don't know about I'll give you widgets'
with the things I know about I cannot
help you with those other widgets it
looks at the default values that's
correct so if I had changed that to a
float then the it would be a floating
slider yes very good question what about
this window function doh it's gonna
needed to be a window can a window be
negative it cannot be negative can this
widget be negative
it sure can it doesn't know window it
doesn't understand that window is a has
any physical meaning it just came up
with a widget for you it doesn't know
it's magic but the magic only goes so
far
so exactly so you can
though we'll get to that in just a
second so basically the magic gets you
one step and then if the magic if that's
all you need it you're done you go on
with your life you have success great
took you one second to try it out and
it's trying to design to fail gracefully
so that the things that doesn't know
about it just doesn't do the things that
it does wrong well if you don't want it
to be negative don't drag it that way
okay so it does what it can it's true
it's a really helpful kind of stupid
friend all right so what if we break
this down though we can actually do a
lot more with this when the magic isn't
enough like what if we didn't want our
widgets to be bubble what if we wanted
to be there to the right
what if we only wanted one of these
widgets we didn't want one for Sigma my
boss doesn't know stigma that sounds a
Greek Oh No
so you want to hide that okay well now
we can look into what the magic is
actually doing and we can help put the
right values for the window so we'll get
to that
so first we'll dress doubles question
which is well let me just go ahead and
show that it works first whoops
lower case okay
first you'll see first let's see what we
we've got and then let's see how we got
it what we got now is two things
we got window to start at one physically
realizable a window can be one or higher
okay so how do we get that well we got
that by telling passing in an extra
keyword argument to the interact
function saying the range of window okay
so we used our human knowledge of
understanding of windowing and we're
able to express that for the interact
function okay your magic is not enough
here's a little hint so we gave it one
hint okay what else do we get here we
also got this cool drop-down then it
allows us to select the different
columns in the data set how do we get
that looking back at the code we again
gave a keyword argument and we told the
told it the possible values of variable
we gave it a list of the columns in the
data set see that now it doesn't have to
do magic it knows what variable can be
and it lets you choose those okay so
you're helping the magic alone and the
other thing that's happening here is
that we can actually oh we also told
Sigma to be in a more reasonable range I
don't remember what it was before oh it
could have also been negative so Sigma
can't be negative so we told it that all
right so we helped out the magic a
little bit we also printed this object
so if we call interact we get the the
result displays automatically so if we
just do this sorry if we just call it it
displays automatically but what if we
try to grab a handle on it
and print what we've got instead then we
can see what was returned from interact
is not a monolith it's monolithic thing
it is actually a compositional thing it
is a column composed of a column and a
row okay if you look back at the
original you can see it is a column and
in this one this bit is a column this
one is a row with one item in it so okay
and then what's in there what's in the
column a selection widget a integer
slider and an integer slider and what's
in the other one you might put lib plot
okay so this now that we've got those we
realized that this magic bundle that is
dropped on us it's not a dead end we can
actually work with that so let's let's
work with it let's take it reorganize it
everything so now I said no the widgets
were up here I don't want them to be up
there I'll put them on the right I'll
put a label I'll tell my boss what to do
how did I do that I took the original
structure here and I indexed into it I'm
going to now make a panel row the
consists of item 1 0 which is the plot
item 1 0 so this is just list accessors
so we're using lists accessors to access
this this is a list of lists or a list
of lists of then it can be a list of
lists of lists of lists however many you
want so you just access something in
this compass it data structure and then
make a column over here consisting of
some text which is actually in markdown
that's how we got the bold it assumes by
default Texas markdown and then we put
one widget in another widget and we
ignored the Sigma widget see how that
works
and using this technique we call this
approach shortcuts not dead ends we give
you a quick shortcut interact but it is
not a dead end it is a shortcut it gets
you this way and if you want to go over
here you just do a little bit more work
as opposed to a dead end which is here's
the magic
you know like magic go install tableau
so we don't want that answer all right
so where are we alright so we were able
to come up with this non dead end thing
where we could make our own thing also
you can see that if you really want to
care about the details if you still want
to mess with the the Sigma there is
nothing special about it being shown
together these things are reactive
objects that if you display a widget
anywhere will it will still update it
and it also is a it's available for you
in Python as well if you want to mess
with it yourself it will update maybe
you see how the plot is updating even
though I'm just fiddling with this you
can watch the widget if you're not
blinking if you do this you'll see the
widget value change right so basically
this composite objects you got is
totally not add it in because you can
pull it out you can put things around
you can mess with it in Python you can
set up a callback function that messes
with it you do whatever you want so
you've been by magic given this bundle
that is
probably often useful and it's not a
dead end you can do what you like
alright so now it's time for you to play
so exercise one is pretty freeform and
they get more freeform after that
exercise one is to do something right
some function that does something if
you're having trouble with matplotlib or
making plots just make it return a
number make it return some text whatever
you can panel if you just write P and
panel and give it something like 45
it'll it'll whatever it is it'll display
the thing and if it's a mad lib pot it
will display a plot if the bouquet plot
it'll display the plot if it's the SVG
or a PNG or a JPEG it'll display that
thing so get something you might want to
display like figure out and think of
anything if you want some inspiration
click on this link you can see lots of
things like equations or pngs or
different plotting libraries YouTube
videos I don't know whatever you want
you can at the moment stick to the pains
section we'll get to widgets and
exercise to you so the goal is to get
something that displays on its own and
then to write a function that has some
arguments and does something so let's
just do some live coding of the sort
that you might want to do return Arg x -
okay and then try this so what happens
if you do in our equals one
okay so here's here's a panel I just
created see how exciting it is it's got
a widget I drag it something changes you
do that to make the thing make sure
function return and strings or numbers
or something write some function with
some number of arguments
and then use interact to make it an app
yeah
and call one of us over to help you wave
a red flag or whatever if you totally
have no idea what you're doing
or you've hit a roadblock and you really
want to find out the answer yes in this
case it's realized that Arg is an
integer by inspecting the default value
and creates an integer slider because
it's a default value it realizes that
the thing it's returning is a string
because it checked return to string and
so we called it once with the default
arguments found that it returned to
string and that's what's displayed it
should be able to return if should be
okay even if it's changing type all the
time but we should try that yeah so it
doesn't have to it just displays
whatever comes back from that whether
it's an integer as it is in this case or
it's a string in these other cases that
make sense so essentially you've just
got a function and panel knee you need
to make sure the function has a default
value or panel can't figure out what
what the what the allowed values are and
it needs to return something that could
be displayed
whether that's a string and integer or
image or whatever that's the only
requirement here and so basically try to
get something to work if it doesn't work
talk to your neighbors or call us over
if it does work then think about it am I
done is this function gonna work like
what if every time I drag that slider it
takes ten minutes what am I gonna do
that so try to understand the
limitations of what you did because that
leads to everything else
or the thing you've got here what if I
need to click on that and change the
font of it how can I do that I mean try
to come up with something that is not
solved as well as whatever you've solved
try to figure out a need because that's
where we're going after this and I'm
checking time now
looking good so I'll give you four
minutes and then I'll ask to see how far
along people are you can keep working at
that point if a lot of people are still
heavily into it
I'm J Bednar at github if anybody is
wondering so you were trying to read my
badge
so David NAR
yes memos
in many cases we haven't published a
generic interface for that we would love
our contribution for that akin to what's
in streamlet I should have mentioned
streamlet as a new competitor
there's streamlet wallah and panel or
basically the end - those are the four
current hot libraries for dashboarding
streamlet takes a different approach
which is to memorize essentially
everything all the time
because it reruns your entire code every
time you drag a widget so you if you're
gonna do that you better be memorizing
some things to cache them whereas panel
allows every which--it to be tied in in
the specific independent computation and
so it doesn't come up as often but it's
certainly it can be useful and we who
support it in some cases
Stream Li T streamlet lets you use your
own browser streamlets really don't like
notebooks because it lets use your own
browser your own editor your own full
IDE it have all syntax highlighting and
everything refactoring whatever you is
in your editor and every time you hit
save streamlet will re-evaluate that
file having cached results along the way
and update what's on the screen so
stream that helps you work with an
independent file the caching helps there
and it also lets you write something
that where they come to the as you drag
widgets it's cached streamlet focuses on
the low end of what you can do it makes
it super easy to put some widgets and
put something on there and then in it
hasn't been around very long and it kind
of has a dead end like oh wow that looks
cool that was great what if I want no so
it can it has it's as a really strong
case for a certain type of usage and a
few years from now it may expand to to
handle the types of things a panel can
do but panel was built on bouquet which
has been in development for since 2012 I
guess it's been it is a mature and
established library panel is new panel
is sort of easy to use features on top
of and support for other libraries the
book I didn't have panel is saying okay
building on what's in bouquet which is
rock solid been there a long time and
really covers all sorts of complicated
situations that people have any thought
of yet
on that basis can we build something
that's much easier for a data scientist
to use something that works well in
Jupiter notebook something that makes it
easy to make apps right away so that's
what panel is so it's built on this deep
and wide foundation stream millet is
there's no default foundation it is
exactly what it is today
and it could could have a great future
so it's fun to be this is a really good
time to be trying to do dashboarding in
Python because we've got four power
players all watching the blog posts from
each other and say hey I could do that
and battling in the blog posts yes
oh you wait till the next section good
question
okay is anybody so deep that they can't
be bear to be pulled out of it okay and
so show of hands how many people
successfully did anything all right
excellent that's actually uh you can go
home I mean anything else is a bonus as
I said my ambitions are low if you want
to have high ambitions there's a YouTube
video of me at sci-fi this summer three
hours long being much more ambitious if
you can handle listening to me for three
hours you go from zero to very
complicated big data Geographic
applications whatever but that is much
that takes your head getting your head
around and takes kind of buying our
entire stack panels one of the things we
work on we work on a whole bunch of
things and that whole group is called
hollow viz panels one of the products
there but it's the one that reaches the
most people I say products this is all
open source we don't make any non open
source all right so we're going from
there that was exercise one you did
something
how many people saw a limitation like
something like this you know one was
just pointed out there what if I want my
widgets to depend on each other like if
this one might be a maximum value for
this other widget that's a limitation
I'll tell you how to address that anyone
else see a limitation are like like oh
looks like it can work but what about
this anything like that yes
yeah that's right so matplotlib and
jupiter notebooks have a long
messed-up history of how it interacts
with the notebook how it displays saying
the typical thing about plot libous use
MATLAB in line and then it doesn't then
your figure doesn't get returned like it
normally if you take something at at
Python prompt and just write seven seven
is returning it's displayed you put a
string there the string is displayed but
if you do a matplotlib figure in line
what's returned to some kind of garbled
meaningless text and then it also
displays your plot panel requires
whatever you do it has to be returned
because otherwise panel can't get ahold
of it you might see on the screen but
panel can't get at it so you have to
make sure that when so the code up here
from Apple lib is specifically making
sure that it returns a figure not just
displays a figure and that's what makes
everything else work so you need a
function that returns something that is
displayable and then interact will work
that is your one requirement and
matplotlib
and jupiter could have been written to
do that way they met the Jupiter
interface term applet lib ten years ago
could have been written that way it was
not it was written to display it as a
side effect inline in I don't know who
wrote it I don't want to meet this
person is weird but it can be made to
behave quite reasonably there's nothing
wrong with Matt but lib it's just about
the default interaction when you use
inline in in the notebook so don't do
that do this yes
correct yeah it wouldn't confuse panel
it might confuse interact in which case
you would need to give interact a hint
just like you do for displaying the
ranges you can also do a hint that tells
it don't pull out try to plot that thing
it will almost certain in normal cases
it will ignore the things that doesn't
understand if it finds something and
you've realized oh it's paying it into
that very I really want to ignore it you
can pass a little hint it has never come
up for me so I don't remember the syntax
but it there is code to do that and
that's the same for interact in I buy
widgets it's got all sorts of ways to
give it hints okay any other limitations
or problems or you're anticipating I'm
gonna focus on a huge class of
limitations which is essentially what
happens when I drag this slider what
happens when I drag it is it calls find
outliers and it generates something and
displays it well what if that function
takes more than a second if it takes
five seconds as I drag this you can
easily start to lag behind what I want
if it takes five minutes
you better not drag that thing you might
want to click like that and then we come
back you see that now those doesn't mean
you can use it you can't use it for
functions to take five minutes you
totally can but if you use interact
you're gonna have a not very usable
display because any change to anything
will result in the entire set of
computation being redone so interact is
a great way to get started if your needs
are modest
but if you want to do something complex
like have these interact in some way as
was mentioned you can't use interact and
if you can't accept that this one
function is going to be called every
time you do anything in the GUI then
you're gonna have to do something more
complex just as an example the more
complex one I don't know if they're
still running here yeah so this is a
more complex one and what's happening
here is
to regenerate this whole data would
require iterating through a billion
points yet here I'm dragging this slider
and it's immediately updating this kind
of cool mountain range thing how is that
working and I can turn off the the data
as well that's all immediate the reason
that's working is that this is actually
a pipeline of operations and these
sliders only affect the very last step
the data doesn't have to be rear-ended
for me to change its opacity that is
happening at the very last step in the
browser and I can actually change the
underlying plot underneath that that
also doesn't require rendering the data
because this is an overlay of data on
top of a map
I changed the map I don't have to
revisit the data so each one of these
things I can change the color map of
something immediately doesn't have to
read and write the data but if I wanted
to change what I'm computing that's
going to regenerate the data and
probably you can't see cuz I chose a
weird color map but in fact it's still
computing it's gonna take a while we'll
take five minutes but that one is going
back to the original data in real
reallocating everything and so this is a
panel app where each one of these things
has been very specifically tied to the
computation that the disease so you can
get the fast things fast the slow things
are slow because they're slow but you
don't have to get this little things if
you don't need to okay
you can do whatever you want this is a
column of widgets it can be a column of
widgets with text there one thing I
don't think maybe zhun look and correct
me on this I don't think we've ever
implemented the hover text for each one
of these it is supposed to be there we
already have ways to declare it but
Bucky didn't make it easy to to make the
hover appear but you should be able to
every time you have some variable have
associated ticks that hovers if that
doesn't work right now then it's we just
have to make the right person listen to
us yes
display the error the error will often
go off into lala land
depending on how you created this if
it's if you made it in a do promote book
this particular one is in a different
note book that was saved to disk and
then it was deployed at a command line
and so on that command line there will
be messages printed and also there are
messages printed here in the JavaScript
console in this case there are no errors
so I'm happy but if you look at your
browser's JavaScript console some errors
will go there if they're generated at
the JavaScript side so if I were doing
something here and there were some
coding error and it realized that some
variables undefined that will show up in
your brawls or browsers JavaScript
console it depends on your browser how
to get to that this particular one it's
under more tools developer tools for
Chrome but each browser has its own way
to get to the JavaScript console yes
pipeline
so we're we're wearing outside a panel
for this question but it's a good
question panel is happily displaying
stuff but what it's displaying can be
arbitrarily complex and in this
particular app which I'm reloading and
it's waiting on but for this particular
app it's using a program called data
shader data shader it takes datasets of
various types renders them as a fixed
sized array and paths and that array is
only what's sent into the browser so the
way that we can have a million billion
data points here that we had earlier was
a billion data points are in Python some
memory or even not it can work out of
core using desk the data points can be
on your disk
it aggregates them renders of them into
something a fixed size array that
something gets put into a binary
chunk of data that binary chunk of data
is sent to the to JavaScript and the
browser the JavaScript and the browser
scales and puts that on the screen and
then you see it updated so at no point
is the data ever in your browser with
this program it is a rasterizer so it's
a handy one because it lets you be
independent of the capabilities of your
browser and python
you can do that but right now it's just
using the default which is that when
okay when you interact with with this
plot to drag it around or whatever
bouquet realizes that the range that
needs to be plotted has changed bouquet
asks Python okay and I'm out of date
give me the new stuff you weights you
still see the old stuff you saw it
earlier anyway so it has the new stuff
okay got it put it on here so there's
the the data is actually not stored
anywhere it's just requested by the
browser the browser's in charge you the
user are in charge us your requests if
pythons not there to satisfy it nothing
ever happens for instance on our website
if you just go to data shader at org and
try out some of the plots they might or
might not actually do anything you go
and zoom in on this thing well it's just
in the browser it does an update because
there's no Python this is just a website
it's just sitting there with a static
export of my file
javascript is happy it does the stuff it
computes the new range it says python
give it to me and no one ever answers
it's very sad actually but that's how
the website can work so the data shader
website has no Python backing unless you
click at this very top then you can get
a running version of it when you click
on that a Python process is launched and
or well there's a Python process sitting
there a session is launched on that on
that process so in this this is what you
see in a static export of something that
uses data shader is that nothing
pythonic ever happens okay anyway that's
data shader another in our family of
tools and it's using a program called
Holub you used to do it another in our
family of tools I'm here to talk about
panel so back to panel all right we're
worried we're finished exercise one okay
we ran up against a limitation of of
interact was is my conceit that we
played around with interact and with
whether you did or did not just imagine
at some point you hit a wall
you can't force things in to interact
you added some hints you added some more
hints but you want to do something that
doesn't really fit with interact
find you can drop down a level and then
work was widgets directly so if you do
that you can do the same stuff you did
before but here instead of using magic
of interact we explicitly say I want a
widget in fact I want two widgets first
you create a couple of widgets here one
of them is an insulator just like you
saw before but in this case I didn't
want that drop-down menu I wanted one
with with these things you can actually
give that as a hint to the interact but
let's pretend you couldn't
let's explicitly make a widget like that
now if we did that and we just look at
that one widget okay I've got a widget
it doesn't do anything but I've got a
widget and the same for this other
widget so you can just make all the
widget you want they won't do anything
until you do something with them so this
is just a way to explicitly start making
widgets so let's say we made a couple of
widgets all right and then having made a
couple of widgets and you can see at the
panel website all the widgets that are
available there are lots of options all
of it originally published by bouquet so
let's say we made some widgets now how
do we get to where we were before with
interact it's actually quite like what
we're doing before what we do but here
instead of saying I'm going to magically
inspect this function and make this blob
here we make some widgets and you're
going to decorate the function and
connect up the widgets to the function
how many people know what a Python
decorator is how many people do not okay
a Python decorator for the people who do
not the typical thing you use it for is
to take a function and transform it into
another function so you've got some
function you decorate it that little @
symbol means to decorate that function
so that this line doesn't do anything on
its own that line applies to this one
and it transforms this function that
takes a string and a an integer and it
transforms it into something that can
take widgets that's what this does it
expresses a dependency between some some
arguments and some widgets
makes sense so here we're declaring that
this argument which is a string actually
should be hooked up to this widget which
is this button this radio button widget
that allows you to select between
various strings okay and the same thing
for the other one we say this window
argument is actually I mean they're the
same text but they're here this is an
argument here that's referring to this
thing in the global namespace which is
this insulator so we're connecting this
radio button in this insider to this
text and this integer argument so this
function here doesn't know anything
about widgets but we've transformed it
into a function that does know about
widgets and in particular it knows about
these widgets and it connects those
widgets to these so unless you write
your Python make some widgets and then
connect them up okay and so now when you
do that your widgets work you can select
everything you can put it together in
columns and rows just like you did
before this is the same thing that you
got out of here it's still a panel if
you print it
it's a blob it's not just a blob though
it's a compositional thing one of them
is a function one of the column in the
column is some markdown and a couple of
Fighters that's what we are seeing okay
so we've just gotten rid of all the
magic most of the magic instead of the
inner magic of interact we're explicitly
thinking about what would its mean we
might want we're explicitly
instantiating them and we're explicitly
connecting them up to the function okay
hopefully you can see that we're not
relying on magic as much anymore you
make all the decisions about which
widget you might want and not want about
what the ranges are here the ranges are
declared when you declared the widget
yet about it starts at one and goes to
60 you told it that you can tell
whatever you want
there's no it doesn't discover it
there's no magic it does its thing
because you told it to okay so this is a
very explicit way but it's not much more
code really it just requires you to
think about widgets and in functions
differently than the interact one the
interact one said dammit make this thing
interactive this is taking a step back
alright I'm on a project now I'm gonna
make some widgets I'm gonna connect them
up it's a slightly different task but
the result can be a very similar yes you
have to pass the hint that tells you the
type of widget you want I never do that
so I don't know the syntax but it's in
there somewhere
the interact function takes tons and
tons of hints so if you want to deeply
like double down on interact and only is
interact there's probably a way to force
it to do the things you want in very
many cases me I say uh I hit some bit
wall I said now I don't know I'm just
gonna make it myself whatever you want
okay exercise to do the same thing you
did before but now start with some
widgets whatever the heck wouldn't you
want and then connect them up using this
dependence decorator with some function
that displays something viewable you
already had a function to display
something people just copy it so it's
some widgets in front of it and add this
little dependents thing
so it'll be something like this you make
some widget you make a function the
function has a dependency declaration
and then you lay it out as a panel row
or column or some combination of that
okay all right have fun
oh by the way how many people are
running locally on your own laptops how
many people are in the cloud happen an
cool glad it's working out both ways the
local one you can take with you the
cloud ones will turn off tonight so
that's we're paying for that yes yes I'm
just checking to make sure we're not
over time we got plenty of time okay
great
right here so we can do whatever we want
we can have right here it's a row of
this plot and some widgets so if we want
the widgets on the left or both places
we put them on both places
it's a row of widgets plot and more
widgets and if we don't want that we can
have a peon dot column yeah now we can
do a plot with the widgets and then a
column that has a plot and some widgets
there's obviously a bad design but do
what you like and this is not the only
way you can do row and column panel has
other things you can do it you can have
it you can say divide up your whole
screen into grids and put something on
this grid cell and this grid cell there
are lots of options this is one of them
we try not to overwhelm there's a
responsive mode correct
yeah it doesn't know how wide this
widget is going to be when it's doing
that yeah there you do in this case you
do peon panel P&I panel is a function
that turns whatever the heck you give it
into something the panel can deal with
it and so if I do that it won't have
done anything at all but it gives me a
way to now pass an argument to this
which is with equals
which isn't working for well because me
of the row also needs it I don't know
but basically you should be able to pass
pass arguments to whichever one needs to
be controlled
whatever the reason that is not
achieving my goal there but but yes you
should be able to anything that can be
displayed is displayed by calling this
function on it this function can take
arguments what that function does is
like me and up panel five if you see
what that is it's a string so I can
instead do and pain that's true it's the
same thing
so basically panel delegates to some
pain class if you go to the panel
website you'll see a whole bunch of
possible pains panel tries to detect
what is this thing and allow you to pass
arguments to it if you want to do have
more control you figure out what that
thing is then you can find out you can
do the help on the end of pain and see
what our arguments it has and so it has
bear it has a good number of arguments
and then you can mess with those yep yes
you can throttle I don't know a way to
throttle it's a panel level when we do
throttling we do it at the underlying
plotting library that is a that is a
good question the author of panel
happens to live in Berlin so he's not
here today he was here actually a couple
weeks ago he can answer that for you
that's Philip rüdiger it's and if you go
to panel it have a link to our git er
site you can chat with us we're also
setting up a discourse site that sort of
question is is well address there
because yes as you set up complicated
apps with you'll want progress bars to
appear in the right spots you want
throttling panel does have progress bars
throttling is an answer I don't know
it was great that we have not covered
that but I will answer that pretty
quickly and so if you have something
that's working for you in a Jupiter
notebook you do dot show and it will
launch a web server on that particular
port this particular is a very
unambitious dashboard but it works
anything that you can display basically
anything that is the result of PN panel
or pin row or column pretty much
anything you can display just a dot show
to it and that's mainly for debugging
because it it means that you still have
your jupiter notebook running we've also
launched this separate thing and then
we'll get to what you want to do when
it's not debugging but well when it's
not debugging what you do is go to your
command line and if you actually want to
launch it separately you will do so
I'll make the text a little bigger but
it's too small for me to read to do that
okay so what I did was take a backup
copy of the talk that I was showing and
then run a command called panel serve on
that and what that did is run through
this all the cells in this notebook
it's a backup copy because I've been
messing with the one I was showing you
who knows what's in there by now but
this backup copy is what I started with
no actually I ran the original instead
of the backup I should stop that okay so
there so I took a run this command
called panel serve and gave it my
notebook and what it's going to do there
is go through every cell in a notebook
and execute it and if it finds something
that can be served as a dash board and
I'll show you what that means it will
serve that as a dash board so it it
launched something at this URL I could
have run this on an AWS server and it
would make a fully public thing this is
just running on my laptop so it's not
public but okay so it it launched this
thing now what is this thing you
actually have to look back in the
notebook for something a little trick
somewhere in my notebook I put a little
hint I did took some panel object and I
said it dot servable that does nothing
in the notebook but what it does is if
you save your notebook and your right
panel serve everything that's been
marked servable will now be launched as
a as a dashboard so this is how when I'm
showing you these things any of these
apps behind this app as a notebook a
notebook was saved a disk on a third
server somewhere in digitalocean there's
a command was run panel served the name
of the notebook this thing in the
notebook was mark servable and that's
what got served so it allows you to
easily transition between a notebook
fiddling around debugging a standalone
server deploying a standalone server and
leave it running forever these things
are running it examples top obvious comm
they're just running forever for until
when they go down they restart and so
these are public deploy
things if you visit them and you start
messing with it something happens in
Python and it starts consuming memory
somebody else visits it eventually the
machine's gonna go down this is there's
a Python server behind it with a real
computation and real data and real
actual work to do it's kind of unlike a
typical website which just bumps it all
down all it has to do is deliver some
bits to your browser here when you hit
something things happen on a server
costs are incurred and so that that's
both good and bad it means it's bad
because if you wanted to be Bank of
America and have a website this is not a
good way to do it there's a million
people visit it it crashes immediately
but if you're a data scientist and you
want to get your work out there and you
want to leave your work in Python just a
great way to do it
so that's who our audience is supposed
to be alright so that's this is the
selection called deploying panels if you
do this on your own laptop this will
work like it will launch this thing if
you do this on the cloud server I
actually haven't tried it I don't think
it's going to do anything because your
cloud notebook is totally firewalled in
something that only shows one port and
that's the one that has a notebook on it
that's gonna launch some other port it
succeeds it it's running they're waiting
for someone to contact it but all the
context to it is being blocked and
firewalled so you can run it but you
unless you're on your local system where
you have the authority to start a web
server in the end that is not gonna be
firewalled then it won't do anything
useful so this is the section of
exploring further called deploying
panels we just told it a little did it a
little bit earlier and just so you know
this is a little trick that's useful in
a notebook that lets you use the same
notebook for a notebook and for a
deployment panel doesn't know anything
about anything it it when it's when you
call panel serve on it it may as well
been a dot Python file UI panel doesn't
require notebooks doesn't need to know
about Jupiter there are separate things
that make it work well in Jupiter but
panel doesn't depend on Jupiter so you
just write a straight panel take this
thing paste it into a Python file use
the panel serve on that
so you're fully independent of Jupiter
if you have security concerns about
deploying Jupiter
there's no Jupiter the Jupiter is there
for you to play around with not for
deployment yes yeah occupancy was up
here somewhere we made it's up here
that's just the name of it it's a you
can put it you don't have to put that
but it gives you a it gives you a name
to the deployment you can see it right
here if you can read that it's that's
that string is showing up right there
it's just the title of the webpage when
you serve it what should you serve it as
in this case you should serve it as
something that is occupancy so that
string shows up there if you leave it
off it'll show up as bouquet or a
bouquet server or something so if I
always put the string because if I
launched six things and they all have
the same name but otherwise they're not
important okay so that's so we skipped
ahead to the plant to deploying we have
one more section here we have a little
bit of time and this part I'm not except
expecting people to succeed at this is
everything up to now
you've been able to use whatever
flooding library you want I don't know
how many how many people actually try to
plot in any library so I figured a few
but you could you could totally do it
you just have to set it up and put the
data there and so on that's fine at this
point when and it would have been the
same for any plotting library because
all it is doing it's calling a Python
function and dumping out the results
anything that can dump out an HTML or
SVG or PNG you can it can work with it
at this point let's get to the ones
where you have committed to a particular
library let's say you're working with
plotly or you're working with bouquet
these two are libraries that give you
interactive plots not just static tuff
of something at that point is when you
get to do really cool stuff but you have
to commit to a library so everything
else is general work for anything at
this point onward we've picked the
library we've chosen to use
a wrapper around bouquet called HP plot
a tree plot just a quick way to think
about it is if you can do Panda stop
plot you can do panda at HP block and
just stop plot gives you a PNG and this
HP plot gives you an interactive full
book a figure so let's say we've
committed to that you can do it with
plot late there's nothing special it
just has to be we're going to do things
where you now have an interactive plot
where you can drag things around and you
can you'll be able to tie specific
actions to events that happens in these
plots and so on so in this case what do
we do we just wrote this one-liner
actually HP plot replaces the matplotlib
plot there was like seven or eight lines
this is just give me a simple H bouquet
based HP plot and this HP plot supports
this syntax where you can take two plots
and overlay them that's overlaying this
background plot with these outlier dots
so that's all this is doing it's just
giving this data and this data where the
second one is the subset of the first
plot the first one and then plot the
second one not as the default of a line
but as scatter plots that are orange
okay so we just wrote another function
here and we passed that function into
our previous find outliers function so
we didn't need to write a different find
outliers function we just wrote a
different plotting function so if we do
that we can do just the same thing we
did before we get a column in a row and
a sum panel and oh here's where I'm
using that trick I could have just put
that text but here I wanted to make the
text wide and not say hello to my mother
and be able to put a parameter on that
text so okay and then make make a little
app here this is actually less work than
the original matplotlib it is not
dumping out an image like that was this
is jumping out a bundle of JavaScript
and it just it's great you work with it
if you look at the code for this
somebody did a lot of work on some
JavaScript I didn't do that work I wrote
that
and so it's relying on more JavaScript
magic
but otherwise it's the same as before
yes right yes
there's not always a server so if you go
to the like I showed on the data [ __ ]
maybe you weren't here yet on the day
share website figure our various
websites you'll immediately see HTML
Javascript or whatever sometimes there's
Python behind them sometimes they're not
and if there's Python behind it amazing
things will happen if they're not you do
things and you think oh that should have
an effect and it doesn't that's
basically so there's some class of
things that'll be exported statically
and you can do more work to make that
class larger but you need the Python
backing if you want access to everything
and so okay so here's what we did this
is just showing off a tree plot this is
just getting us in the door gives you an
interactive thing what we really want to
do is do deeply more complicated things
like this in this case so here we've
tied the hover we figured out what our
exposition is in the hover and we've
used that to update this table over here
this is the sort of things you're gonna
get to but you have to commit not just a
panel but to a particular plotting
library and how to connect up things in
that plotting library so that's not
about panel it's about whatever you see
you're showing panel did not make the
connection between this and here you
made the connection you're just
displaying the things make sense so you
have to learn whatever library you want
to use the tools it has available for
doing that we're using HV plots tools
use whatever you like but here we were
just to give you a flavor for it what we
did is create in HP plus built on Holub
use hall views has this idea of streams
this particular one is a stream that
listens to the exposition of a pointer
so that stream all by itself when it's
given a source in this case this line
plot all it will do is when the pointers
in that plot it reports back the
exposition of that pointer it's up to
you to do something with it what is it
doing here is
updating this table we were set up you
noticed this depends now we're depending
on this stream instead of depending on a
widget a widget is a way to get a stream
of values from a user a stream stream is
awaiting a stream of values from
anything and in this case the stream of
values comes from not from the user
doing widget but a user hovering all of
us doesn't care just accept streams of
all sorts of types so connect steps
streaming data user events periodic
events whatever in this case so we're
creating a tap stream really it's not
tap it's I mean that's just bouquets
term but all it's just showing you where
your pointer is so you could tap and
it's connecting it up to the table so
what if what it does here is in this
plot in this function it connects it to
this line and it says that's the plot
I'm watching in this function we're
saying here's a function that's watching
you here's a function that's watching
that and so that's what makes this table
over here depend on what happening
what's happening in this plot over here
none of this has to do with panel per se
actually this depends on underlying
library called per am it's been echoed
into the panel namespace that's a that's
a implementation details strictly it's
not panels problem how you connect
things up we just put it there as a
nicety so what this does is allows us to
write a few functions allows us to have
one function that returns a plot and
then we do just the same thing we did
before we again called interact we call
it and fold find outliers and we pass it
in this new function H we plot to that
just does a little bit more it sets up
this connection to the to the tap source
otherwise it's the same thing we were
doing earlier and so up to here the left
and the right was exactly the same
things we were doing before we had some
variables we had a plot it's just like
this one right
instead of view fun equals HP plot it
will be you be funny equals a tree plot
too otherwise it's the same code and
then we added one more thing which is to
create this table in this table just
effectively filters your data frame
so anything you could do on a data frame
you could do in a function like this and
display it over here so and we're
watching the pointer XY we could watch
anything we like we can watch the y
coordinate the x coordinate what data is
selected a you can have a selection tool
here which it doesn't look like there is
but there you could have a box selection
tool and the thing over here can be
watching whatever it is you selected or
whatever and that's how we implemented
the things like that's how this was
implemented it was watching the X&Y
location this is also hall of use based
this particular example in this case I
don't know if that's still running but
it's watching a selection region when I
select a region here it every one of
these four things is watching that
selection and whenever that selection
changes up that plot updates this plot
updates this plot you know that
selection is actually a conjoint
selection across all the plots so every
there's a selection object and anything
you do on any of them goes into that
selection object you know all the plots
update when that selection objects
change so if I want to look at only the
things in Europe I can select the
European things that have a certain
temperature that have a certain
precipitation whatever what's happening
is that there's an underlying selection
object each one of these plots is
watching that depending on that
selection object that selection object
is also depending on the blocks so this
is more complicated code to set all that
up but it's the same idea that you just
saw all right so exercise 3 is on your
own time it just says do something
you've already basically used the time
because other people are waiting
but basically exercise 3 was just
opening it anyway
and then where to go from here we
already covered this section on
deploying panels and then you can go
from there we've covered interact and
widgets there's a totally different
third way to use things that allows you
to be completely declarative and never
declare anything about widgets but have
everything also be specified use that if
you want and then just follow the rest
of those pipelines is one particular
thing to point you to obviously it's a
but if you look for pipe lines at the
panel website you'll see pipe lines give
you a complicated multistage app where
you've set some parameters it does this
and you select here and you finally get
to the thing you want if you want that
there's a it's an easy thing to do
so there's it can have a much more
complicated thing if all you want is a
simple pipeline of series of steps
that's actually pretty easy so don't
think of that as a hard thing think of
that it's an easy thing everything else
is hard after that all right enjoy thank
you
[Applause]